and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review Toy Story 3 Oh
Jackie's the greatest movie I've ever
seen in my life to infinity and befores
dear see you Bowie named Andy only he's
not a little boy anymore
he is a grown young man on his way to
college and so he doesn't need toys
anymore
Oh dance bullcrap who doesn't break a
choice to cut it I brought my toys to
college
wait a minute I went to college women it
I had toys wait a minute I am friends in
tuna so all his toys our friends are
gonna get thrown away so the toys make
it over 20 chairs Center and all the
toys are so exciting they're like creepy
we I got played with once so let you
drink um in and they play with them way
too hard and toys are like this mug on
the Knights room with the nature toys
and the other toys are like silly huh
galore heroes inside these plastic cages
and I grab Buzz Lightyear into her
around the gears I control in by turning
on the jerky mode I think that's the
mode Glenn Beck has been ever wet it's
almost like you're capable hostage but
meanwhile woody comes what he tells all
the toys that he is going to rescue them
but the toys are like duh boys like
don't worry thinking I will take care of
it right think you got it
how come your voice sounds different
uh-huh so what'd you think stop the evil
monkey and mr. Potato Head yourself by
turning himself into a mr. tackle day
hey I remember mr. taco head he was
there when I drop dancing at Taco Bell
but so I have to switch buzz back to his
original setting some party tortures Ken
the super metrosexual by terry embodies
clothes no please don't about my
jockstrap I won't be able to protect my
non-existent genitalia
I have no genitalia once no story to
tell some how to fix buzz but
unfortunately they make in Spanish hello
me llamo Spanish oh oh but enter that
Jesse the cowgirl doesn't mind because
bench people are hot just like sorrow
whoa
Miley you must like you back to normal
the pen looks like I'm gonna be burned
alive by a furnace boy toy story got
really dark didn't I mean it's like you
get Frankie burn alive the permits are
you Rock pass but they say but the
threesome artichokes and the only Pepe
ever is selling us no but he turns and
eats okay yeah go and use the toys away
to this little toddler girl and he's
like these are my toys
this is rags and Buzz and Woody now Rex
is strong he'll look after you forever
and buzzes determined he's the most
determined spaceman around and we know
like prices at 17 and I'm going to enjoy
it
we I'm a child again I'm in shock again
I don't ever want to grow up I don't
ever want to grow up but my college is
like we got given wealthy the end so 23
3 is a wonderful wonderful movie but
sheesh guys lighten up it's a cowboy and
a spaceman not Lorenzo smile
incidentally did you know I was in the
movie high with the oil this is jittery
boom scene change - I forgot
yeah Magi come on July sometime just
method toys the children